It's important to note that many of the data sets that
we've used so far in this course are what I would
call tidy data sets. What I mean is that these data
sets were manipulated into a specified format of rows and columns.
This is what allowed us to so easily import these data
sets into R. You should know that not all data sets
are going to be so nice. Sometimes, you may be pulling data
from different sources, like webpages, audio files, or even PDFs. Other
times, you may need to reshape or rearrange your data into
different formats. We're going to cover this later in lesson five. The
important thing to know is that this is a necessary step
prior to conducting EDA and it's called data munching. There are plenty
of tools for doing this kind of work, and if you're
interested in learning more about how to wrangle and adjust data,
check out our data munching course. You can find a link
to it in the instructor notes. Now, this course EDA won't cover
data munching, but techniques for doing so are vital for any data scientist.